はい、それではですね、いよいよワークフローの作成に入っていきます。今回はですね、ミニチュア版ChatGPT、なんちゃってChatGPTなるものを皆さんと一緒に作っていきたいと思うんですけども、その前にですね、実際に私たちが目指すものは何なのかというのをまずははっきりとさせるために、重要なAIオートメーションとAIエージェント、この2つのワークフロー構成について皆さんに教えていただきたいと思います。
n8nで作成していくワークフローというのは、大きく2つに分類することができます。
これらがAIオートメーションとAIエージェントと言われる2種類の構成となるんですけども、まずはこのAIオートメーションについてお話をさせていただけたらと思います。
AIオートメーションといった形でして、特徴としましては一方方向、一方向の処理フローというのが特徴になります。
順次処理型、線形構造と言われていたりするんですが、これらはですね、Aが起きたらBをする、
Bが起きたらCをする、Cが起きたらDをする、というようにあらかじめ決められた動きしかできないワークフローになります。
実際の最初のインプットから最後のアウトプットまで決められた同じ動き、常に同じ動きをする一方方向の処理に特化しているという、そういった構成をAIオートメーションと言われています。
実際の仕事の場面で言うとですね、定型業務と言われるような毎度同じ業務処理が行われること、こういったものとかと非常にイメージがつきやすいと思うんですけども、
このAIオートメーションですね、あらかじめ決められた順次処理型の構成というのをAIオートメーションと言いますので、一つの構成のパターンとして皆様押さえていただければなというふうに思います。
それに対して、AIエージェントなんですが、実際に本日作っていくミニチュア版ChatGPTは、こちらのAIエージェントに分類されるものとなります。
大きな特徴としましては、動的判断と並列処理、このような特徴があります。
いわゆる先ほどのAIオートメーションとの違いというのは、AI自身が動的な判断ができるといったところが非常にポイントとなります。
あらかじめ決められた動きではなく、ユーザーのインプットからAIエージェント自身がどのような動きを取ることが良いのかというのを判断をしてくれる。
そういった特徴がございます。例として挙げるのは、優秀な秘書のようなイメージをいただければと思うんですけども、
例えば秘書に、何々さんにメールを送っておいて、そんな資料を出したら、秘書というのはどんなことをするでしょうか?
おそらくですね、その秘書というのは何々さんのまず連絡先というのを探して 連絡先が見つかったら次にメールの本文だったり件名っていうのを作成して
それが準備できたら最後メールの送信というようにですね このAIエージェント自身が与えられた目的ゴールを達成するために
AIエージェント自身が持っているこのツールの中からどれをどんな順番で使うべきか、AIエージェント自身が判断をしてくれる、また実行してくれると、そういった動的な判断というのが可能なものとなっています。
この動的な判断というのが、AIオートメーションとAIエージェントの一番の違いでありまして、実際にこの講座を通してマスターしていただく革新部分といっても過言ではない部分ですので、
AIオートメーション、順次処理型、決められた動きの処理をしていくものと、AIエージェント、動的な判断をするワークフロー、この2種類があることをまずは皆様押さえていただければなというふうに思います。
ですので、本日はこのAIエージェント、なんちゃってChatGPTを皆様と一緒に作っていこうと思いますので、再度ですね、こちらのキャンバス画面の方に戻っていきたいと思います。
それでは実際にAIエージェント、なんちゃってChatGPTの作成を進めていこうかなと思います。
まずはですね、どんなワークフローであっても絶対に欠かせないのがトリガーと言われるものになります。
トリガーとはですね、ワークフローを開始させるためのきっかけのことですね。
身近な例としては、メールの送信ボタンであったり、SNSの投稿する、投稿ボタンですね。これもいわばトリガーの一種なんですよ。
ボタンを押したら実際にメールが送信される。ボタンを押したら実際にSNSに投稿される。といったように、こういったトリガーというのはどのワークフローに関しても絶対に必要不可欠な存在になりますので、
まずはこのトリガーというのを追加していこうかなと思います。
ということで画面中央、add first stepと書いてあるこちらのプラスのボタンを押してみます。
そうしますと右側にトリガーのメニュー欄がたくさん出てくるので、こちらから色々選んでいくといった形になるんですが、
トリガーにも様々な種類がありまして、今回は実際になんちゃってChatGPTということなので、
ユーザーがチャットでメッセージを送信したこと、これをトリガーとしてワークフローが動く、このような仕様にしたいので、この右側のメニュー欄からですね、
On chat messageというこのトリガーを追加していこうかと思いますので、こちらをクリックします。
そうしますと、こういった画面になりまして、こちらBack to canvas、もしくはこの枠外ですね、こちらを押していただきますと、
このようにトリガーが追加されました。これでですね、実際に追加、まずはトリガーが追加できたよということですので、まずはワンステップOKだと。
あとはですね、先ほどもお伝えしましたが、Save、これは都度で編集を加えたらSaveを、都度でつける、これをですね、癖づけるようにしていただけたらなというふうに思います。
はい、ということで続いてなんですけども、トリガーが追加できた続いてに追加しなければならないのは、このチャットを受け取る先ですね。
ユーザーの入力したチャットを受け取る先の ノードというのを追加する必要がございますのでこちら中央プラスボタンを押していただいて
はい今回はこちらこのAIからAIエージェントというこういったノードを追加していこうかと思います
そうしますと、こちらBack to canvasもしくは枠外の方をクリックすると、このようにノードが追加されました。
これでですね、実際にユーザーからのチャットメッセージを受け取るAIを設置できたという、こういった基本的な流れができたかなと思います。
それでは再度製造して実際に動くかどうか テスト実行してみたいと思いますのでこちら画面下Open chatと
書いてあるところから何かメッセージを入力してみたいと思います。 では今回はこんにちはと
このようにメッセージを送ってみたいと思います。 更新、そうしますとこのようにエラーが出てしまいますので
せっかくAIエージェント、ユーザーのチャットメッセージを受け取るAI Agentノードは追加できたのですが、実際に応答を何もしてくれない、エラーが出てしまった。
これはなぜかというとですね、こんにちはというメッセージを受け取っても、まだこのAIエージェント自身が考えることができない、
AIの脳みそなるもの、考える力というのがまだ付与されていない状況なんですね。
次のパートは、いよいよこのAIエージェント自身に考える力というのを与えてみたいと思います。